so another thing about us we were
talking about is uh uh failure like I
had my big failure in
1982 like in my
case I um made terrible call in the
markets and whatever it is and I went
broke and I uh lost money and I had to I
went so broke I had to borrow $4,000
from my dad to take care of my family
bills and and so on very painful but
that goes down in my mind as one of the
best experiences I had because I had to
learn about okay what do I do what the
lesson you know and I've got this
principle pain plus reflection equals
progress I I know you had your own
failure uh well there were many along
the way and of course in in the NFL when
you play um every week you have the
successor failure there's the report
card uh it's it's pretty clearcut so
again you learned that job security is
is based on performance and anything
that gets in the way of performance is
affects your job security uh that was
pretty evident again in Cleveland when I
became a head coach you know after
spending 12 years with the Giants and
went to Cleveland um even though we went
from a you know a bad team when I got
there 3 and 13 to you know to a very
successful you know 11 and 5 12 and 16
in '94 uh then a down year '95 and and
uh that was the end and so you know when
I reflect back on the 5 years in
Cleveland I look at some of the things
that I I failed at that I you know
needed to do better in the next
opportunity and you know fortunately uh
in New England um Robert Craft and craft
family gave me an opportunity to you
know to resume a head coaching
opportunity there in uh 2000 and you
know I tried to take a lot of the
lessons that I'd learned from the
Cleveland experience um which a lot of
it was good but again the things that
came up short I tried to implement those
in the in the new opportunity in New
England and along with the supportive
ownership um that's worked out pretty
well your attitude uh I think is very
similar
like
pain provides lessons many times right
absolutely see the pain on the front end
or pain on the back end it's either the
pain of preparation or the pain of of
failure and so it's it's I try to put it
in on the front end don't always avoid
it on the back end but do everything I
can to not have the results be
painful